you look at box you look at BuzzFeed you
look at salon you look at CNN they say
your race your gender it is your
identity it defines who you are that's
very different from saying hey here's my
pocketbook - hey this is who I am this
is what this is the makeup of my soul
and that is entirely a lie simply to
pander for votes that's more off-putting
to me more off-putting to me than saying
I could write a check for a billion
dollars is someone lying about being
engine let's get to Elizabeth Warren's
top five campaign lies I think this is
important we've done with some other
candidates especially since right now
Elizabeth Warren is the front please be
Elizabeth Warren I want to see the
election between Donald Trump and
Elizabeth Warren so badly the easiest
out is that way horse can be hilarious
and and let me know the reason why is
Donald Trump doesn't really apologize no
he doesn't waddle back and he's already
gone to Pocahontas I know that's gonna
be hilarious so I'm very curious as to
where he takes it from there let's give
you some context here line number five
and this is a big one the lie that
Elizabeth Warren perpetuated out there
that Bernie senator Sanders said that a
woman couldn't win the presidency for
people out there who don't know I think
most of you at this point
there was a story that that went out and
I remember I was sort of not reading a
ton of news Christmas through New Year's
and so is coming back in I understand
what it's like for you guys it's tough
to digest it's like drinking from a
firehose and so you read it and
sometimes you assume why would someone
lie about that and then you realize
Chris Cuomo makes sense now you connect
the dots right so the story out there
and I was on CNN that's where I
originally read it and was covered
everywhere was that Bernie Sanders told
Elizabeth Warren or made a phone call
and said that a woman couldn't win the
presidency there were no sources
provided by the way no legitimate
sources it was denied outright by the
Sanders campaign okay so I want to be
clear to set that context claim no
corroboration no source denied by the
Sanders campaign and then the CNN
moderators polled
smooth live with Bernie Sanders you are
saying that you never told senator
Warren that a woman could not win the
election that is correct senator Warren
pretty clear what did you think when
senator Sanders told you a woman could
not win I disagreed back pocket full of
anthrax just after the debate Elizabeth
Warren confronted Bernie and but this
seems so staged
because the CNN recorded it but they had
the right camera angle and the mic still
going and then they aired this footage
[Applause]
let's not do it right now whatever that
discussion will have that discussion you
called me Lee
you told me it's classic Bernie for that
one the only one we will I don't here's
the thing I think that he's wrong but I
do think there's a he's a godless man
who's trying to do the right thing now
his mind the right thing involves
killing babies and stealing people's
money I get that true but he did try and
take the high road yeah there which I
appreciate you trying to dodge what's
obviously an attack but just think of
that rule think of that rule according
to Warren you know this made up
something that's an indictment on
someone's character and when he corrects
the record he's accusing her of being a
liar and of course again kekekeke claims
and he's never said that i believe him
lest you think that i have no reason or
context to believe that bernie sanders
has a track record of saying that a
woman could be president the real issue
is not whether you're black or white
whether you're a woman or a man in my
view a woman could be elected president
of the united states the real issue is
whose side are you on
again I don't like Bernie Sanders but I
do appreciate truth can we say woman can
become president and also he looks like
the scientist and a weird Nickelodeon
show that he's very kid-like
through evaporation precipitation by the
way this is something else that really
bothered with Elizabeth Warren they were
after this some people are coming out
accusing Bernie Sanders of being as bad
as the me to rapist crowd the rapist
defender trap yeah so a prolific and
well-respected journalist and I hate
this because sometimes you'll get this
on even on CNN or shows like The Young
Turks or like Trevor Noah though the
people and they bring up a tweet from
some random person with two followers
and it's just two other eggs eggs so
this journalist writes for place
Washington Post New York Times GQ
gentlemen's quarterly for the
uninitiated Julia LOF she tweeted I want
to make sure I get it correct still
thinking about the warned Bernie
squabble and I have a question to people
who have accused warren of line isn't
the lesson of hashtag me to in the last
few years that we believe women and
don't call them liars
I thought the lesson which by the way
was ill-founded was that we always
believed women who make accusation
accusations of rape but I don't believe
that but now you're saying we have to
believe all women on everything now that
extract we've expanded that from rape
culture which isn't a real thing right
to anything a woman says ever yeah that
is so district yeah writes this by the
way for GQ gentlemen's quarterly I am
suspended yeah your subscriptions are
shrinking Wow is ready for gentle hey
what's in this week's edition month
edition of GQ is it how to wear suits
how to pull off a skinny tie no way men
are pieces of pieces of pieces of and
there's an ad for Armani Cologne that's
about it study my quarterly ass-kicking
for being a man I'll read this manga GQ
that's a [ __ ] gentlemen want to read
about all men being liars okay so that's
line number five let's look at the
Elizabeth Warren's
track record on the truth kind of
outside of Bernie Sanders yeah number
four soon was a big one a lot of people
may have forgotten about this she
claimed that she was fired for being
pregnant
yeah so she contract was renewed for the
next year and I was all set to go but I
was pregnant at the time wasn't showing
yet about two months later when I was
visibly pregnant about six months along
the principal called me in and said that
he wished me luck
but he'd be more comfortable having
someone else in that job and he was
going to hire someone else for the job
and that was it I lost my job a
component of that may be true in that I
too would be comfortable hiring someone
else but as nothing that you are with
child no you would be more comfortable
with anyone else and it has nothing to
do with your miracle of creating life
school records here's important they
show by the way that not only was a
contract unanimously renewed she was not
fired she resigned that's different yeah
she was I that's what I almost predict
no she wasn't fired she resigned unless
you think that these former employers
are lying it actually tends to match up
with the unofficial testimony of you
guessed it worked it was in a public
school system but I worked with the
children with disabilities and I did
that for a year and then that summer I
actually didn't have the education
courses so I was on an emergency
certificate it was called and I went
back to graduate school and took a
couple of courses in education and said
I don't think this is gonna work out for
me and I was pregnant with my first baby
so I had a baby and stayed home for a
couple of years she looks older back
then
what happened it's terrible when you
rebut yourself I have no idea imagine
being the person who who has anyway I
don't want it I can't get her name she's
unattractive yeah there's not a
definitive claim sure it's not opinion
it is yeah I find you repulsive but not
not in here we have some people in the
studio here who you know take what they
can get threading the needle carefully
which we will not do the notification
bell if you are on YouTube hit all
notifications because there's another
step right now better hit the bell and
then there's gonna say all you want to
go to all seeking all the notifications
get the streaming over here you don't
get the live stream if you don't hit all
okay and of course we have new videos
that go up every day it's at 8:00 or
9:00 Eastern and of course that's why we
do ask that you join my club letõs
credit.com /mo club there's a lot more
content there the entire blaze catalog
because these rules keep changing that's
how we stay in touch with you line
number three she claimed that her
children attended public schools there
needs to be a little bit of context here
a woman told Elizabeth Warren that their
children had different opportunities
because warns children probably went to
private schools and Elizabeth Warren
immediately corrected are saying that
they attended public schools okay now
that seems pretty cut and dry yeah does
meaning a lie here's the thing I don't
have you know that's about John Edwards
actually my wife had read the book I
don't know how many books are on John
Edwards it seems to be once you get to
the point where he's making a sex tape
with a pregnant lady while his wife has
cancer in the hospital you close the
book and go oh he's the villain done
yeah you think yeah but he used to buy
like Armani suits like expensive Armani
Versace's you go boss ketone suits and
then he would take out the tag and so in
JC Penney's really yes he would do that
because he wanted to seem like he was of
the people this is what the Democratic
it's like the fake rappers getting shot
in the face stories to have street cred
they're just like you their kids went to
public schools look he Shops at JCP I
think they call it man of the people but
I don't understand this why is it bad if
your kids went to a private school why
is it bad to wear an Armani suit at
least president Trump kind of owns it
he's the one guys I guess he goes out
there I'm really rich and the middle
class needs some help that you can have
bogans he couldn't deny it at this point
though no I don't think way too far past
anything he embellished it yes I will be
the first trillionaire and bi will be
mean and so kids did go to public school
for like a semester I couldn't find out
how long but for the majority of their
school careers they went to private
schools with tuitions ranging from
seventeen thousand to forty thousand
dollars a year all right why number two
she claimed that she was too poor to
afford college now this is important
because again it doesn't match up with
her other claims rate Jill Biden asked
with this Elizabeth Warren claimed that
college wasn't affordable in her day and
that her parents couldn't afford a
college application let alone putting
her through college by the time I
graduated from high school my folks
couldn't afford a college application
much less to send me off to four years
at a university so like a lot of
Americans I don't have a straight path
story she say I don't have a straight
pant story I don't know I thought she
was talking about boot cut that straight
cut now here's your here's the truth her
parents didn't put her through college
because she went to George Washington
University on scholarship dropped out of
college to get married ended up going to
another public college for $50 a
semester which she herself tweeted out I
want to make sure I get this right so I
go to mine on prompter don't you love
this iPad tech I got my degree thanks to
a quality public College where tuition
was just $50 a semester that kind of
opportunity doesn't exist for students
today again I don't care that she got a
scholarship I don't care that she went
to a community college I think that's
actually a good point that $50 is Mester
there's a way to make certain colleges
affordable but the problem is we have to
contradicting narratives here first you
have the one where she was a poor child
who's just a poor black child who
couldn't afford college then you have a
second that it was so easy in her day to
go to college because it was so cheap as
opposed to today and it depends on who
she's talking to and what bill of goods
she needs to sell and that's what
bothers me ok line number one I think
you could have seen this coming
I'm sorry I get it but actually we did a
whole segment on this and we had to
remove it because I was wearing the
Socialists a t-shirt from the Asian bill
knows that but it's available at Mudd
Club so it's a little more in depth and
Jimmy Norton is coming up after this
being the Irishman we'll be talking
about the film nominated for the Academy
Award line number one her do what's the
word engine it's something a lot Indian
is offensive wait till you see the clip
oh and then I have I have a microfiber
cloth for the egg on your face she's
repeatedly used the supportive as
opposed to street cred of being Native
American as a talking point and just as
a refresher on the campaign trail my
father's parents said absolutely not you
can't marry her because she's part
Cherokee and she's part Delaware my
teller had high cheekbones like all of
the Indians do oh she said it not which
I they all have high cheek every one of
them all of them all of them no one else
really no one entirety no I mean
countries she didn't just dabble in like
oh I'm part Native American she wrote a
cookbook about it she went out this year
she was speaking on reservations she's
not she's not the DNA test that she took
to prove which is remarkable to me this
just shows you the ego on these people
like someone should have advised her
this was a bad idea she took a DNA test
to prove that she was Indian her words
not mine and it actually showed that she
may have less Indian blood than your
average non-indian American a whopping 1
in 1000 24th huh native by the way for
reference here's my 23andme
I am about as much
Saharan African the show and I just sort
of drop an end bombs I wrote a book
about the plight of black the history of
slavery here's my twenty three sounds
absurd it is exactly the same the
percentage is entirely comparable here's
what's really sinister about it though
not that someone lied about their
heritage that's kind of crappy but you
know maybe you do it at dinner parties
to make yourself interesting once the
conversations sort of reached its end
with reverse aging gimmick here's the
deal
she is claimed repeatedly that even
though she's part Indian Native American
she's never benefited she's never used
it I never used my family tree to get a
break but that it had I never used it to
advance my career question the book deal
powwow Chao figment of our imagination
doesn't it doesn't because she she
actually had to give the advance back
because the book sold so poorly Oh sold
or not but just assumed it had nothing
to do it that's because she was a woman
oh sure
she'll never win Yeah right or not or no
one's reading yeah even now no one's
reading it because of gender bending so
was it term turf anyway that happened
during the break I don't wanna get into
it not only did she sell a Native
American cookbook she used her Native
American identity to land a teaching job
at Harvard ooh in there law review I
have a lawyer here hailed her as being
the first woman of color hired they're
getting a little loose with the
terminology aren't we I think is
important because we know people will
say well Donald Trump lies granted he
does okay no one is perfect but the
difference here is that and this is just
my opinion and I want to hear what you
think Donald Trump exaggerates actions
right Donald Trump what he has a
tendency to do there's a difference
between lying like a sinister lie
and being a bit of a [ __ ] artist
yeah anyone who's ever worked in sales I
mean you know that you're selling a car
this is the best car on the lot right
it's a stereotype for a reason he will
exaggerate right the the length of his
successes and then he'll diminish maybe
the depths of his failures right so
Donald Trump yeah I get it in other
words he might be worth three billion
that would 7 billion okay no excuse me
7 billion loss I'm gonna the Deutsche
Bank it says you were three billion they
are fake news every news outlet it's
just a Jewish account name and they know
the minute you like Donald Trump may
have been a good athlete in school but
even I was the best athlete in school
okay Rudy wishes he with me he's like
Rudy wasn't even that good of an athlete
because he wasn't me that's what I've
said so he exaggerated s' actions and
he'll diminish his failures maybe hey
how many times have you filed bankruptcy
never well okay I get it your businesses
file bankruptcy not you personally so I
think that that is different sort of
exaggerating or maybe embellishing
actions versus Elizabeth Warren who
misrepresents who she is
she misrepresents who she's as a pretty
make no mistake we all laughed at Rachel
Dolezal remember the the fake black and
I see P Sideshow Bob hair it's no
different than this one and here's the
thing this is so important when people
out there when you read you look at box
you look at BuzzFeed you look at Salon
you look at CNN they say your race your
gender it is your identity it defines
who you are that's very different from
saying hey here's my pocketbook too hey
this is who I am this is what this is
the makeup of my soul and that is
entirely a lie simply to pander for
votes that's more off-putting to me more
off-putting to me than saying I could
write a check for a billion dollars is
someone lying about being engine
mm-hm you know what's in here it's just
water that's why they call it acting
what it actually smells garlicky there's
something wrong with the water I think
it's going through the icemaker and we
don't have we don't have the baking soda
in the fridge if you liked this video
subscribe hit notifications or just
check back every single day because we
upload a new video every single day this
is actually taken from the full show a
full hour show the way upload every
single Thursday click that right now go
watch the entire show if you don't want
to you don't you don't have to but if
you if you stop by you know just don't
bother me I'm gonna enjoy my garlic
water